alors monsieur étant dit vous êtes
l'inspecteur général pour la sûreté et
la sécurité nucléaires à edf je suppose
que vous suivez avec beaucoup
d'attention ce qui se passe dans cette
centrale nucléaire d'union soviétique
est ce qu'à votre avis est ce que vous
confirmez vous les informations des
américains selon lequel il y aurait de
très nombreuses victimes très nombreux
morts non j'ai aucun moyen ni de les
confirmer ni de les infirmer
je veux dire que dans toute cette
affaire ce qui est extrêmement gênant
c'est l'absence d'information officielle
de la part des soviétiques
je veux dire d'ailleurs que j'ai
téléphoné à l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique à vienne et on m'a
appris que le directeur général de cette
agence fait un suédois lé dr blix a
demandé au gouvernement soviétique de
fournir des informations techniques le
plus rapidement possible alors pour le
moment le mal est là on a le sentiment
on pense que le coeur de la centrale est
en train de se consumer c'est ce que
l'on appelait le syndrome chinois dans
le club adverse g chinois mais c'est
normal quelque chose de très grave et
qui met certainement les exploitants
société dans une situation très
difficile car je crois que leur problème
majeur c'est qu'ils ont eu un accident
samedi que cet accident dont nous avons
vu des traces très minimes en europe a
certainement fait sur le site même de la
centrale sur les bâtiments
une radioactivité très importante et que
cette radioactivité leur complique
considérablement la vie pour attaquer un
incendie qui déjà en soi ne serait pas
très facile à atteindre
oui j'ai cité tout à l'heure la corde la
conversation entre un radio amateur
soviétique un radio amateur japonais sur
radio amateur disait que les secours ne
pouvaient pas arriver à cause de cette
très importante radioactivité autour de
la centrale
oui je crois que la radioactivité doit
surtout être concentrés sur la centrale
elle-même mais que de toute manière les
soviétiques ont balisé
un périmètre de sécurité alors qu'à lire
sur toutes les routes
ils ont mis des postes de police pour
interdire la circulation
il est très vraisemblable qu'ils étaient
accrues des milliers de personnes ils
ont certainement évacuer des personnes
qui n'ont pas couru de risque immédiat
pendant l'accident mais étant donné
qu'il ya eu des dépôts de radioactivité
si on l'avait laissée si on les avait
laissés sur place j'aurais effectivement
pris les doses d'irradiation mais le
nombre exact quand on n'a pas
d'informations de la part des
soviétiques est difficile de dire qui on
ne motive en europe qui dans le monde
s'est tu
été maîtrisé ce type d' incendies c'est
à dire le coeur qui se consume
bon je crois que si on peut accéder à ok
ça ne pose pas de problème il suffit d
tout fait et je pense que différentes
méthodes par exemple répandre de la
terre sur le blog du réacteur n'est la
terre avec le buldozer en répandre
parrot est quelque chose de tout à fait
faisable
néanmoins on peut également cet effet
dans un réacteur anglais il ya une
vingtaine d'années éteindre en envoyant
du gaz carbonique de la mousse
carbonique
le tout c'est à lui de prendre un
extincteur ou l'envié de plusieurs
dizaines de tonnes en et je maintiens
que la difficulté que doit avoir les
soviétiques doit être le niveau de
radioactivité locale ce que vous leur
avez proposer vos services d edf que je
représente ici non je crois que la
france a officiellement proposé son aide
à l'union soviétique
on a parlé tout à l'heure du nuage
radioactif qui se dirige vers l'autriche
et la yougoslavie tous les français qui
nous écoutent se demande si ça va venir
chez nous et si ce nuage sera très
toxique
alors si ça va venir chez nous ça je
crois qu'il faudrait demander aux
spécialistes de la météo
le par contre la toxicité l'on peut être
catégorique ça ne présente absolument
aucun danger ça n'a présenté aucun en
scandinavie et plus le temps passe plus
ça se dispersent
est ce à dire totalement insignifiant en
tout cas cet accident remet est en cause
ici les principes de sécurité que l'on
est en vente et un petit peu partout
dans le monde
oui là aussi il faudrait en savoir
davantage parce que n'oubliez pas que
les soviétiques développe un type de
réacteur qui est quand même très
particulier et on aimerait bien en
savoir davantage sur les causes de
l'accident avant de remettre tout en
course merci de ses premières
explications monsieur tanguy l'union
soviétique add ons